jack
he is a professor of
physics
at berkeley here and he has done a lot
of work in cosmology and also beijing's
typical method
so please join me in welcoming euros to
give a talk slice to normalizing flow
optimization and something yes thank you
thank you for inviting me and and i will
actually be talking about geometries a
lot actually i think so but we'll see
what the connection is it will be
interesting uh
uh so uh my talk is in two parts first i
will talk about normalizing flows and in
particular specific moments in flow
which is based on optional transport
slight optional transport
i thought i would cover that because you
know part of this workshop and this
program is about optimal transport and
so but then the more important next part
is how we can use normalizing flows to
improve the geometries of the sampling
and to actually do sampling okay so
that's that's uh the plan of the talk so
what are normalizing flows normalizing
flows on maps
from some simple let's call it latent
space
where distribution is simple and i will
be always using
uncorrelated gaussian with zero mean and
unit variance a simple
base distribution and then through the
maps through this nonlinear functions
let's call them f
uh which each of which is supposed to be
simple but then you know a collection of
them together can create something very
complicated like like a distribution
that looks like this
so these maps are bijective so we and
we want to be able to both invert these
uh individual maps so they need to be
simple to invert
and perhaps even more importantly we
want to be able to compute the jacobian
of the transformation so that we are
able to compute the density of the
of whatever we want to estimate okay so
the basic two applications of
normalizing flows are first we can
sample from the latent space and create
samples which look realistic and the
second goal
uh which as i said is more important for
the for this uh discussion here is that
we can estimate the density of the let's
say some data
uh with this uh you know framework
okay so one the example uh just to you
know get started suppose
suppose we train on the on the entropy
suppose we train on the on the mean log
p
uh you have some training data uh x uh
so x will always be data here
uh and
um so how do we train this thing uh we
for example we try to maximize the
entropy um
uh you know maybe we start with
something simple uh this is the data
distribution this is in latent space
doesn't look very good but after the end
of training you know maybe we have
created a function that looks like this
uh and we have managed to map
this distribution to a gaussian
okay and so then once we do that as i
said we can both sample and we can
evaluate the density in the of the data
in the data space p of x
okay so in one day it's easy
of course the situation gets much more
complicated in high dimensions
and again the most important aspect of
noticing close is that we are that we
parameterize this this uh as a
maybe flow but where we can do the um
both the inverse and the jacobian uh
easily so that we can actually quickly
evaluate them there's a lot of
normalizing clause in the literature
some are actually continuous based on
audis even pds
so they're not nice connections there
but uh the one i'll be talking about is
a slice iterative normalizing flow
because i said it's based on optimal
transport and it's a paper that has been
accepted that is similar
um so
the motivation is radical transform
so why slices the motivation's random
transform
random transform says that
any probability distribution high
dimension for distribution can be
described
as as an integral over one-dimensional
slices okay so that means this is a
statement that you can you know this is
a universal approximator this lysis can
be universal approximately you can
approximate any verbal distribution with
just slices
uh cat scans are a great example of this
uh what they do in the brain right you
you uh you project
the
the map whatever it is
in different directions
you do the slices in different
directions
this is the input so-called sinogram
then what you do is you fourier
transform
you have to
then apply it with this
kernel which is key dependent uh and
then you uh you know align these fourier
transforms um
on a circle um and then you inverse for
your transom and you get an image of a
brain
so uh
what is the issue in general uh when we
scale these to high dimensions so this
is a two-dimensional example and
we had you can see we had a lot of
slices
as we go to high and high dimensions we
get of course the curse of
dimensionality
uh it is uh you know impossible to do
all possible slice directions and an
average of them
okay so then what is the next best thing
that one can do is uh
to actually look for directions of the
largest distance between the slices
so here uh is where uh i guess optimal
transport investors and distances come
in
um so let's first
we can write in the random transform we
can write
sliced slice p versus and distance which
is the basically the distance between
two two distributions in terms of the
slices right so the motivation is the
random transform and we can write this
um as
basically one dimensional distances but
then integrated over all possible uh you
know the sphere in this dimensional
uh volume so this is obviously still
very expensive and we haven't solved
anything
now instead of that what we can do is we
can look for the for the directions of
the maximum voltage time distance
uh maximum slice voltage and distance um
and so that's basically we're looking
just for the slices with the largest
distance and we can look for one of them
but what is much more efficient is if we
look for care of them at once
where where k could be the dimension of
the system or maybe something lower and
then these would these are then
orthogonal to each other these
directions and that means we can look
search for these directions
of large uh deviations between two
distributions uh we can look
look for them all at once
all right so this is basically how our
method works um
imagine you're trying to map one
distribution to another let's say you're
trying to map blue to to orange orange
is our target
blue is this one um so how do we do this
um we first do an optimization problem
where we're looking for directions
which maximize the this the the distance
the vastus and distance on this slice
uh so this is an optimization problem
where we're looking for direction
so for example uh
in this case for example we found in
this direction there's a very large you
know vasculation distance between these
two distributions
okay so then in the next step we apply
this normalizing flow idea and we map
along the slides the two distributions
all right so along this particular slide
the two distributions now
are equal
so we use basically
splines to to do this mapping
and then of course in the high
dimensional space we have not achieved a
perfect
matching of the two distributions but we
have come closer
right so in now in two-dimensional space
you know now blue looks like this and
it's much closer to the orange than it
was before
so what do we do next well we keep doing
this
right so that's uh how we try to avoid
the curse of dimensionality uh by uh by
this procedure and this is a natural
procedure so it's a greedy algorithm and
at least in the way i've phrased it here
okay so this is the algorithm i'm not
going to go through the details but let
me just uh you know point out this is a
neural network structure in the sense
that these directions are linear
operations they're just orthonormal
matrices
um so these are these weights if you
want and then there are no linearities
which are these one one-point
distribution function maps
um based on this uh you know um
mapping between these two distributions
and these are much more general than
your your standard machine learning
reloads or whatever right these are
basically very very powerful
one-dimensional functions really
um
okay so uh let's see um
does it work it works actually very well
even in high dimensions
here are some examples of a sampling
from this after we have trained on
fashion innis for example uh you can see
how
after one iteration you get this after
10 iterations you get this and then you
know after a few hundred you get you
know pretty good uh fashion clothes
um here are celebrity images for example
and here's just uh various samples from
our trainings uh on amnes fashion
amnesty c4 and and celebrity
uh so these are high dimensional
examples right the uh mdc 784 uh these
these guys are more like three thousand
so this is clearly
can work as a you know as approximately
very high dimensional proper
distributions in terms of sampling
now what is i think far more important
for the purpose of this uh
discussion is how well are we doing on
the density estimation and on the
density nation there are these data sets
um from uci
yeah yeah
so in the previous slide when you do the
sampling okay so you you had two so as
far as i can tell you're trying to match
two distributions what are you trying to
match it's like the sample distribution
of one coordinate at a time is that what
you were doing so if you were to go so
here's my question if i were to go to
the number of iterations there to 2500
which is the dimension does this mean
that i'm going to actually because the
dimension this is just a number of
iterations sure so let's say i take this
number of iterations to the full
dimension of the image space yeah it's
always full dimension each each one is
at a full dimension each one no i'm
saying i take the the number of
iterations to be the dimension of the
image space
yeah okay so let's say do this all right
so that means that i've actually matched
all the directions for this vessel no no
no no why not you're look i mean think
of random transformation right it was
two-dimensional doesn't mean that two
directions are good enough right now you
need you know in principle you need all
possible directions right i see okay and
but if i take all possible directions
does this mean that this flow is going
to push to the sample distribution of my
images or or is it going to create new
images that's what i'm sorry sorry what
so oh it's pushing to the gaussian is
that what it's doing uh well in this
case we're pushing actually a gaussian
to the data right in this case the flow
can be done in both directions
right you can either map
match the gaussian and make it after a
flow to match the proper distribution of
data or you can do the other way around
in fact this is why we have two
things which called sig this one is from
the gaussian to the data
and this one here is actually from the
data to the gaussian okay and they are
slightly different actually
thank you
so uh i understand one step once you
have done once after you have done one
step and you have the push forward of
your initial distribution by this you
know one dimensional basically map and
that can be k dimensional right because
you can yeah that's what i was like
so one iteration involves these k
dimensions yeah great okay thanks
uh all right so um
now let's look at the density estimation
um
um so that is uci data sets uh which
come in hundred thousands of them
and they are very horrible looking
actually and they you know in this case
they are you know six dimension to 63
dimensions they're pretty horrible
looking actually
so this method is not really
state-of-the-art necessarily uh on the
full data set so i need to tell you i
have two versions of our method here one
is with low regularization which is very
fast and one with uh with higher
regularization which is slightly slower
so
they do pretty well um
um but maybe they're not quite
state-of-the-art at the
maximum data size but at the low data
size uh sometimes hundred to a thousand
it's always the best our method is
always the best okay
um so that means it has some very good
inductive bias properties
um that is going to be suitable if you
want to approximate probability
distributions in the low number of
sample settings which is what we really
care about when we talk about sampling
and mcmc yes
uh well yes so regularization in this
context is that
there is a realization parameter um well
uh which uh prefers not to do any
mapping so
in other words if um so this is to
prevent overfeeding basically if you
have uh if you were just letting this
algorithm on its own
then it will perhaps overfit even if
you're doing just slices
but the regularization parameter says
okay let me let me let let let's my
prior to be i do nothing and so then it
actually does less than it should have
but by doing less than sugar then on
many many different iterations of this
it actually does better
so can you comment more on the
industrial device do you mean some kind
of english device sorry uh can you
inductive yeah yeah there's some like
increase in the biases yes that's right
yeah yeah yeah right yeah here i'm
comparing two different um normalizing
clothes that are out there there's these
things called math mass or aggressive
flow there is a
neural spline flow these are
state-of-the-art fjord it's all
state-of-the-art right
the other thing i actually wanted to
mention is kde is a very poor density
estimator especially in high dimensions
current density estimation right even
even if you adjust the kernel
uh to the best possible value it's you
know kde uh forget which one settings
this one here uh kd is what orange uh
you see it's it you know it's it it's
it's you know for example look at this
six-dimensional space it's not even that
high-dimensional it's it's really poor
uh for low numbers
this is all on the whole that this is
all cross validation so you're just
measuring the likelihood of your points
on this thing okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is all in crossover this is not a
training data
okay so the other thing that i think is
very good about this method is that it's
actually very fast uh especially on this
low organization which you can see
actually it's not that bad really right
um
uh we get seconds we're talking about
seconds uh for evaluating uh this code
through and other normalizing flows can
be a lot a lot slower all right so
that's those are the two things that are
nice or the third one is very nice is we
actually think we think we have a lot
fewer hyper parameters than other other
codes okay as as you know we all know
hyperparameters are is the black magic
of machine learning but this code
actually has very few of them
all right so let me now move on oh yeah
so one application is uh anomaly
detection
uh
and so here for example we have done
uh there was there was this challenge in
lhc in physics which is not actually my
field this because i'm a cosmologist but
anyway we played this game with them uh
and we did this estimation as a um
there was a challenge they injected some
events this uh
and there was a challenge basically
tried to find this particle and us this
resonance and so this actually is our
result this is actually from the certain
courier it turns out that we we we were
by far the best on this task
even though these people are actually
pretty sophisticated they they really do
a lot of machine learning in that
community but nevertheless these density
estimators are very good for anomaly
detection okay
but all right let's move on now to what
we really care about here this workshop
which is how can we use normalizing
flows
for sampling
um
all right just to remind you uh the task
that we
uh want at least that i want but i
presume also a lot of people here is
that we want to get
this is the bayesian context right we're
going to get the bayesian posters given
some data so now i'm going to talk about
parameters let's call them y and x will
continue to be the data
okay so we want a posterior p of y given
x
but all we know is access to to this
joint p of x and y which is the
likelihood times the prior
and um
[Music]
and so um we all know mcmcs are the meta
of choice and we all know that many
different flavors depending on whether
you have the score or gradient or not
and things like that we also all know
that there are many issues with that the
chains are correlated um
the burn you know the mainnet have
converged the burning problem
and things like that um
so i want to emphasize two things for my
own applications um two things are very
often we have very expensive uh
likelihoods
uh that's because to predict uh like i
don't know some results from some
experiment you may need to run a whole
simulation or or an od or a pd solver or
something like that right so this this
solvers to get the prediction therefore
to get the likelihood can be very very
expensive all right so i'm interested
in this regime where
the likelihood innovation is is very
expensive and probably dominates the
cost
second thing is
uh for better rewards uh a lot of these
um
uh applications you know they do not
this is solvers let's say pd od
simulation whatever they do not have
gradient all right with respect to these
parameters why
uh these you know people are just not
used to
uh
writing solvers and have a gradient
right so we are in machine learning of
course people are used to have you know
bad propagation so they have radio
respect all the powers but when it comes
to some certificate applications that's
not the case all right so
i will also be talking a lot about
gradient free uh
applications which you know maybe it's
not the applications you guys have in
mind because you know as we know uh both
hamiltonian language
dynamics require gradients
uh okay so
so what's the plan here the plan is
let's surrogate the posterior um with a
normalizing flow
now um as i said what we have access is
a joint
uh
well we have no idea where a period is
where in the parameter space it peaks
and where it's zero and of course we
also do not know the normalization
constant or partition function
uh let's call it z um and so therefore
we do not know really the posterior we
just but we are able to evaluate
something proportional to the density
at a given sample
so previously this is a much harder test
than what i was talking about before
right previously we had samples from p
of x and we fitted density now this is a
harder problem
so basic idea that i will be talking
about is
uh what i call an annealing flow
uh
in the sense of the temperature
annealing um but i will also then talk
about and that's because i'm thinking a
lot about these applications without the
gradients but then i will actually later
also show other possible flows
which are possible if you have gradients
okay so and finally our goal at least is
uh to get away with as few
calls of the likelihood as possible
because that's the really expensive
thing for us
and so this is a thing where the the
fact that synthetic does so well with
small number densities is particularly
useful
all right so annealing flow is a
different type of flow than what you
have been talking about but it's still a
flow and so let me actually write it in
the language
of the flows uh so let's forget that uh
let's first talk about the the
temperature dependent target density so
this is where you take the likelihood to
some power beta
times the prior
and so as beta is zero and so at high
temperature
uh this is just a prior and then at beta
is one then this is the target density
that we want to get
so let's also then define the similarity
function
between the target and the current
estimate of the of q
all right now this similarity as i said
can uh can be
for example one that i like a lot if i
don't have gradients is i'm just going
to do log of p minus log of q minus log
of z
because i don't know the normalization
function i have to have it in here and
then i'm squaring this okay
but you could also do kl divergence
but
but scalar division actually will not
work if you don't have trades at least
it will not work very well
uh if you have gradients then one again
that i like a lot is the fusion
divergence so we take a gradient of p
and minus gradient q and you square it
and then just average over all gradients
all right so these are the dissimilarity
measures
now the kneeling flow
i am writing here as
a flow in the density in the probability
density
and it's flowing with beta with
temperature from zero to one
and it's given by some uh
let's call it hyperparameter lambda and
then we have a gradient of this the
similarity times the gradient of of the
uh of the target objective q right and
both these grains are with respect to
parameters of the normal zinc flow so
think of this normalizing flow having a
bunch of free parameters this would be
these rotation matrices this would be
the spline parameters that i mentioned
earlier right this these are all a bunch
of parameters we need to
we want to train them we want to see how
these products are flowing as we change
the temperature from zero to one
okay so this is now you see this
equation uh looks sort of similar to to
vassenstein flow but
it doesn't enforce explicit
normalization why not but because this
normalizing clause are normalized that's
the point of this normalizing right they
only normalize i don't need to worry
about normalization because it's already
built into this into the
it's already built into the into the
constraints of the system
okay so let's unpack this
uh all right so what i'm doing here i'm
literally just just you know doing this
total derivative is a
basically derivative respect to each
parameter times the derivative of each
parameter and so in terms of what i'm
actually solving here
i'm solving for these individual
parameters phi
and
i'm saying the derivative of i is just a
gradient of l so this is just the
standard gradient descent right
but the point here is that i'm keep
changing the target of this gradient
descent right so i keep doing this grain
in sand but the car target itself is
changing because i'm flowing in the
temperature from zero to one
yes
it seems like there could be a variety
for a variety of ways of interpolating
from what you get at beta equals zero p
of y and your target b one why do you
choose this method of interpolating
between the two you mean why annealing
temperature annealing yes yes yes uh and
i will get back to that uh when we have
gradients then you're absolutely right
and i will show some some examples right
but when you don't have gradients
actually then it's it i think it is
kneeling is one of the you know very
powerful and and and good ways to do
this okay
so
so can i have a question yeah so what's
the actual parameter lambda in the
annealing flow um right so
let's see i have it on the next slide
but um yeah let me do it on the next
slide where i uh show talk about
algorithm but basically this lambda is
is giving you the learning rate um okay
so let's talk about the algorithm so we
started beta by drawing samples from the
prior
now i can now i need to discretize of
course this flow right and the way i
will discretize it i'll choose the next
data i would have an adaptive
criterion
and in fact i will do it so that at the
next beta
uh the effective sample size
which is determined by these importance
weights of the new bay of this
you know true uh joint on the new beta
developer uh all beta is uh 0.5 of the
total number of samples okay so if i
draw 200 samples then i want this beta
not to change too much so that my
effective sample size
at the new beta level is still 100.
now i apply these importance weights to
these each of these samples
and now i resample them okay so what
this resampling does is it gets rid of
the low low density
samples which are useless and so you
know it kind of gets rid of them but in
an unbiased way right uh and so this is
uh nothing new this is similar to how
sequential monte carlo does uh does its
job
but now the new thing comes in is that
now i fit uh
normalizing flow
to the new density okay um
on the current samples on the samples
that i have
and uh and i do this uh by using this
synth code or maybe i do this with using
the stochastic gradient descent uh steps
on this similarity function okay in fact
we do both
so this is where optimization comes in
right so this is you know i'm solving
first optimization problem to get a new
uh a new um normalizing flow that
approximates
uh this p at the new beta
and now i need to do metropolis hastings
adjustment as we always need to do in in
longevity mechanics we also need to do
it here
and so the way i do this is that now i
draw new samples from this neutral
distribution uh and uh so this is where
sampling comes in
i evaluate the the this this value on
the new samples and then i compare each
new sample to the old sample
and i use the standard metropolis
hastings acceptance right so if if i
have gone up in terms of the value of p
divided by the transition rate because
this is really the transition this q now
uh if i go up i'll accept it and if i go
down i accept it with some probability
uh and so um i do this several times if
i have to so that i reach 50 acceptance
okay and then i repeat to the new beta
until i reach beta equal to one
so there are a couple of ways to view
this uh one is a marker process view
that i just described
but
as we know market process is has to have
this transition rate
uh and it's you know supposed to be
transition rate suppose depends on on
the on the previous sample and the new
sample
what uh the main determining issues are
as we said the samples can be correlated
and acceptance can be low
now what happens uh with the if i if i
take this algorithm that i described and
i put it into this view first of all
uh the proposal is independent of
uh the positive position from y prime to
uh from y to y prime is it independent
why because i'm just sampling from the
distribution
so these samples are completely
uncorrelated so in other words i have
perfect mixing if i if i have excited
this sample it has
it has nothing to do with with what i
was comparing it it's perfect mixing
okay so that's one advantage
second one you know if you look at this
transition ray what happens if p
if q is actually proportional to p at
that beta
then we have r is equal to one then we
accept all of the samples okay so we
also have perfect acceptance
so those are the two main advantages of
this strategy
of course in practice we will not get q
to be exactly the same as the target but
we may get very close and
uh you know we strive to get to roughly
50 acceptance before we move on to the
next level
okay so this is the view of um
of the market chains but there is
another view
um where you can we can think of these
normalizing flows as preconditioners but
they're very very powerful
preconditioners so not only they can
handle
high condition numbers they can handle
hydration numbers changing across the
parameter space okay because they have
they can handle any geometry you throw
at them
so
um what is nice is that we can actually
do
and and look at basically just in the
latent space what this probability
distribution should be and it's nothing
else but the probabilistic equation in
original space
times the jacobian or the inversion copy
depending how you look at it
so
and so this is nice because we just have
a new new
new target in latent space we can sample
now we know in latent space the geometry
is nice and simple you know it's a
gaussian acrylate gaussian
so you know all of the condition numbers
have gone away right so this is nice if
if your target if you have a good q
all of this goes away and all you need
to do is therefore now sampling in in
with this new target density and you
know not surprisingly right if you write
this target density acceptance rate
uh in um the the hemington hastings
acceptance rate in this the latent space
it will be just this the ratio of these
target densities and not surprisingly
this is the same as the one i wrote on
the previous slide
right in in the mark of um okay but so
we can we now have two options to to do
the sampling one is the one i was
talking ab before but the other one is i
can just do my standard uh metropolis
casing sampling where i just look uh
around an existing sample i draw you
know a gaussian sphere i draw a sample
and you know blah blah right so so we
have several ways of sample and of
course we can also do hamiltonian or
longevity dynamics in this latent space
so this would be uh this romanian
geometry view right where
i have i can now do sampling um
hamiltonian or or longer one sampling
and what is uh interesting is
i can rewrite these equations that i
wrote
in a language
where
it becomes this romanian uh language
of this paper
uh duralami and colorhead
right where they proposed
basically uh
position dependent mass matrix
uh g and they proposed to to use this
information to do the sampling now
unfortunately that's that
that method that they proposed is not
working very well because actually you
need to take a gradient of this metric
of you know the curvature and so it
becomes a big mess and actually nobody's
using that
but uh in the latent space you can still
do this and it's actually you know you
can think of this uh sampling that i'm
proposing here as um
as a way of
doing what they have proposed but in
latent space where it's much more
efficient
this actually uh
uh has been done in hofmann at all and
so for example here they show
um for example in original space you
know these are the samples here there's
200 steps very short steps
uh in the in the latent space you can
see how the initial steps can be very
long and that's because of this jacobian
is jacobian saying okay you know you can
just take long steps um and so the
sampling becomes much more efficient
okay so
does it work um i don't
know
that this is work in progress um
[Music]
but
i am optimistic
um
here's an example that we just recently
obtained
this is ten-dimensional call-it gaussian
these are you know okay not not
extremely high condition number but you
know it's ten dimensions
um you know correlations can be quite
large and most importantly this is an
example where i do not use gradient
information
so the standard thing in this kind of
problems would be either metropolis
hastings or sequential monte carlo
so what we obtain these results so
basically here
there's something red which is truth and
blue which is our result and you can see
the difference because they're the same
in other words we have obtained perfect
perfect result
with in this case 10 beta levels
and with about 3 000 samples which is
several times less than for example
sequential monte carlo
uh needed for on this exactly the same
problem
so i think on this kind of problem this
is competitive uh maybe even beats the
state of the art um and of course that's
our goal that we will be able to get
better samples this way uh this took
five seconds on a laptop
so it's encouraging but of course it
needs a lot more stress
testing on hard distributions
so
um
one reason why these these methods are
useful and you know to answer this
question why temperature annealing is
because temperature is very powerful for
multi-modal distributions
um and since this synth analyzing flow
can handle multi-modal can handle any
distribution
this certainly works very well here i'm
showing two-dimensional example two
gaussians these are these black things
here i'm also showing a bunch of samples
here that i've drawn
this fits to the queue are is red and
i'm also showing the density of the
samples in blue all right basically at
low temperature you know everything is
spread out but there is some affinity to
the where the two peaks are and then as
we go to beta one we zoom in under the
two peaks and we get you know pretty
much perfect result in this case
so
um now to answer why uh why temperature
meaning you know if you have score based
um
sampling so in other words if you have
gradient you can certainly do other
other possible things um so
and um so for example
um the way to think about our uh
our method is we are really solving both
launcher and the focal plan uh you know
where we are iterating on both launcher
and the parker plan right so we're using
uh focal plank density to help us sample
and then we're using the samples to
improve the density okay so that's
that's one way to think about what we're
doing here
um and uh
and so if you have gradient then what
can you can do you can certainly use the
green information to propagate into the
new regions even if you started some
something very far off here's one
example we ran two dimensions uh the
target is this doughnut here we started
at basically a direct delta function and
it's slowly propagated out
okay and in about 10 iterations it it
filled the whole doughnut okay and
that's because you had a great
information this would have been i think
harder
um if you don't have a gradient right if
you just have to do metropolising steps
okay so
uh how much more time do i have
oh okay
all right i'll just quickly mention a
few other applications
one is global optimization
you can also do global optimization with
this kind of normalizing flow methods
now global optimization
especially if you have multi-modal
distributions
is a hard problem and what people try to
do is they try to do exploration and
exploitation right so
and so here the idea is we're going to
use normalizing flow
fits to the function
for um exploitation so because we can
then look for the peak of that uh
of that function and we're going to use
the normalizing flow fits to the density
of samples
uh to look for regions where we have low
density and we should explore better
okay so we explore it and explore with
two different density uh estimations
and this here's an example of this six
hump camelback it has two peaks
uh the we start from this temp 10 point
sample from the prior and um
uh well this was supposed to be a movie
but okay all right now i transferred the
pdf so sorry this is actually supposed
to be movie sorry about that all you all
you get to see is the first slice uh
which is unfortunate but you know the
point of this movie would have been to
zoom in and it zooms in on the two peaks
right and here i have an another example
and again unfortunately i cannot show
you the movie
uh but you know this is a you can think
of this as a low beta situation and then
as we increase beta we're zooming in in
fact we're zooming in on this peak
because this peak is higher than two
peak than this peak right this would be
a double gaussian example
uh and you know in terms of number of
calls here here you know there's 40
calls these things are competitive with
with the state-of-the-art based on
optimization methods um
genetic algorithms
okay and then final application uh is uh
for basin applications sometimes we want
based on evidence normalization constant
and
this one is very easy for normalizing
flows because they are normalized so it
kind of comes out for free
all right
so uh but you can play different games
um here for example we said okay suppose
you have samples
uh you know somebody else ran samples
you know hmc or something like that can
we just get a normalization
by simply fitting a normalizing flow to
it and then do some importance waiting
to correct for it right and that's
exactly what we do it turns out if you
have samples you can do something called
bridge sampling not just important
sampling date sampling is where you use
information both of from samples from
your target distribution
let's say mcmc samples and you can also
use samples from your approximate
distribution q and it turns out that
that improves the accuracy
and so just to give you an example these
are four examples the varying
dimensionality of i believe from i don't
know 10 to 60 or something on that
you know that the bananas funnels and so
on a multi modality
uh oh this is not showing very well
unfortunately but
the here is the the um the correct
answer on the log z
uh and um here for example the funnel
here the results from uh annealing
annealed imported sampling which is you
know state-of-the-art and there's a
reverse uh annealed important sampling
here it's supposed to bracket the
solution which it does uh but you know
as you can see it's it's useless because
it's you know orders magnitude away
um anyway our method is always bang on
so if you ever need an integration
constant um
which and of course this you can use
also just for doing high dimensional
integrals right
um
then i think i think these normalizing
flows are actually a good way to go uh
to get normalization constant
integration constant
okay so let me actually end with uh oops
i'm cutting off one line here but uh
with a discussion just to maybe
hopefully get some uh some feedback
um
so normalizing flows can simplify the
geometry they can precondition
uh and make standard uh sampling uh
methods more efficient
but normalizing flows also have
offer a completely different way of
sampling we're just sampling from the
normals in flow density itself
okay
i forgot to mention um when i was going
to slides but one key
advantage of this is we can draw these
samples in parallel because they just
drop samples drawn from from these
normals include density
so this can be a huge huge uh um for
things that i'm doing for example this
can be huge right because i can i can go
to a supercomputer and just draw you
know 200 samples in parallel
maybe sample is very expensive because i
need to run on pde or something else but
i can do it in parallel
and that can be huge
you know
gain there
now
and of course the samples are
independent
and so the acceptance rate depends on
how dissimilar the target uh this queue
is from the target
uh and so now which of these two methods
are better i don't have a good answer um
[Music]
but i think this approach has a fighting
chance
because it can be afforded to be quite
inefficient
and still win for the simple reason is
it doesn't have to deal with the
thinning of the market chains doesn't
have to deal with
leapfrog steps in hmc and stuff like
that right you know each sample is
really independent right so if you are
um
you know it doesn't help you that
you got a hundred chains if they all um
if they all call it like in my field we
have examples where
uh i mean it's almost a joke right
people have um hundred lip rock steps
each one is a and body simulation it's a
huge cost
and the correlation length is 600 so in
other words
uh they have something like i forget you
know 50 000 uh correlation lengths or
now it's every 50 000 steps of a
simulation to get one independent sample
right so you can see how we can be
extremely inefficient and still maybe
win against this kind of uh hamilton
monte carlo strategies okay so that's
um that's where we are and so what what
what what does this efficiency depend on
i don't know
for sure number of samples uh inductive
bias of normalizing flows uh which
may overfit and so that's something
where hopefully our method is good but
we have to explore it further
choice of the similarity measure that
for sure will play a role
uh and finally of course you know
whether you use great information or not
uh fischer fischer diverse and so on
okay so that's it thanks
thank you thank you euros for a great
talk
so let's take a few more questions
very nice talk i have a question uh if i
understand correctly so this sampling
method what they are talking about is
like a you use normalizing flow to learn
the proposal
right i mean in mcmc we just use a very
simple proposal but you use a
normalizing flow to learn the proposal
not proposal to learn the the target
yeah but uh at every step i mean you
cannot learn the target perfectly you
have to learn a proposal and still you
have a matching budget
target
i mean i don't know what you mean
to me proposal is is the transition uh
yeah yeah yeah that's what no i'm not
learning that at all right i'm learning
in in the leaning case i'm just slowly
annealing yes uh i start from a prior
right which i know yes and then i'm
slowly meaning and at each uh
temperature i learned the actual target
at that temperature and then i slowly
change the temperature from zero to one
okay so yeah that is what i mean by
proposal i mean you have one step
proposal so you claim you don't need the
gradient information or the score
function but in order to learn this for
every step do you use stochastic
gradient descent over there
uh well um yes so
um
[Music]
uh there are two ways to do this um you
know first of all as i said i discretize
the temperature so i don't actually have
that many uh and the second then um we
are we are still experimenting um the
normal i was describing
is not based on stochastic grain descent
uh it's iterative
but you we also have a version where we
are running stochastic gradient sand on
the target uh
in this under the similarity target
right on on the loss function which is
literally the difference between the two
distributions squared and then averaged
uh over the samples drawn from from from
the proposal distribution
[Music]
okay one more question is the in terms
of efficiency so in traditional uh
sampling method you there's no learning
component right you just learn this
algorithm so in your algorithm there is
a sampling component there is also a
learning component you need to update
the parameter so when you compare the
time and this do you also take into
account of the learning cost what do you
mean by learning
you want to you see in a normalizing
flow you need to update your parameters
yeah yeah yeah right no yeah of course
i'm comparing the total time yes uh okay
uh so okay here for example
this is the total number of calls it
went through 10 steps we have learned
ten different uh density estimations
using our method so you know and the
total cost was uh five seconds
uh and the number of uh samples we
called uh was three thousand right the
normal this cost right now yes here it
is dominated by normalizing flow because
it's about one second or half a second
uh but you know imagine that you know
each of this calls was uh minutes or
hours or whatever then the cost of
normalizing flow would be irrelevant
right okay thanks
[Music]
yeah just yeah just a uh simple question
from the beginning how do you compute uh
let's say we consider k is equal to one
uh for simplicity just for simplest at
the beginning right the
sliced normalizing flow
so i understand it it's really
advantageous to take the direction where
they are kind of most different but how
do you find that direction i mean that
problem is non-convex and it is
non-comics i agree um
uh so
um yeah i mean it is an optimization on
the direction right so now it's great in
descending direction um
and it isn't on comics as you said
but in some sense we don't care right
because so what if we haven't found the
best direction then we just do it again
no
okay thanks
any other question okay
yeah thanks for the talk i was wondering
if you could comment on sort of like
what are some challenges for using this
in practice for instance like while
you're running this did you encounter
any like failure cases or like instances
in which like the standard mcmc
algorithm algorithms are better just to
get a yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh no it's not early to say uh right um
maybe i well maybe a different way to
answer if we have tried a lot of things
that did not work right so there's a lot
of failure cases we have kind of crossed
uh ryan
and uh but i'm i'm at least happy that
now we maybe have something that seems
to work
this came we have this as a week ago
there's no paper by the way on this
right
yet
and we'll have to see right so all of
this is still fresh and i don't have any
answers to your question but obviously
that's where we're going right this we
want this to succeed
and i don't know if it will succeed or
not
thank you
any other question
okay even no more question let's thank
our speaker euros again thank you for a
great talk
and we will meet here